neo is an immensely layered experience
through its Dark Souls inspired combat
you're taught the virtues of patience
and the value of defense with each
deaths there's the potential to learn a
little bit more about yourself and your
enemy this team ninja production
demonstrates the studio's penchant for
demanding action driven gameplay that
rewards tactics and high dexterity and
despite all the inevitable dying neo is
surprisingly rich in solutions to
overcome its many hurdles KO a tecmo
fondness for Japan's tumultuous Sengoku
period is on full display in neo the
unusual foreign point of view of
protagonist William Adams adds freshness
to this familiar setting his notoriety
as the first western samurai is the
kernel that allows the gameplay to
glorify Him as a knowledgeable user of
Japanese melee weaponry neo his past the
combat proficiency is partly motivated
by his pursuit of antagonist and word
Kelly both are in search of Amrita a
type of magical stone abundant in Japan
that has the power to turn the tide in
Queen Elizabeth the first favored in her
war against Spain
it's time for your execution
the demands of melee combat and mio
cannot be overstated assuming your
character level isn't significantly
higher than the recommended level of a
given mission some enemies can kill you
with a single stroke at times enemies
fight with unpredictability of a PvP
match you wish in complement these
enemies for their tactical brilliance
that is until you throw your controller
after dying at the hands of a boss for
the 20th time neo is at its most elegant
when you're engaged in a one-on-one duel
many enemies Telegraph a lot information
even before they attempt their first
strike by studying their stances you can
deduce what attacks tend to result from
those poses being able to read your
enemy and emerge victorious thanks to
all this visual information provides
some of Neos most gratifying moments at
its most fundamental level survival in
neo is about managing stamina which
determines how frequently you can attack
an enemy the fact that enemies are
equally limited by stamina creates
tactical and exploitable opportunities
there's heightened suspense and a sense
of realism when you and a foe are
huffing and temporarily immobilized
pleated exhaustion neo empowers you
through a wealth of resources and
choices that only expands as you make
progress you acquire new weapons through
a Diablo inspired loot drop system where
myriad stats and special effects ensure
that no two weapons are alike 5 melee
weapon types a selection of firearms and
the opportunity to learn non samurai
abilities like magic can be a lot to
take in
yet thanks to Neos optional quests and
the ability to replay completed missions
you can take time to find your footing
before advancing to the next mainline
chapter
options for success further expand with
the inclusion of cooperative play which
isn't co-op in the traditional sense in
order for a guest to be eligible for a
host story mission the guest needs to
have already completed that mission this
unfortunately nerfs what could have been
a stimulating session the guests armed
with information on a Maps layout and
the bosses tactics can help turn a
chapter that would normally take three
hours into a 15 minute job
the immense variety and environment is
reflected in the thoughtful pacing of
what will be an 80 hour playthrough for
many there's a rhythmic Evan flow as you
advance through the story
for example after an exhausting to
chapter skirmish on a ravaged
battlefield you're greeted with a less
demanding yet still challenging trek
through a lush and foggy forest with
enemy ninja encampments and much like
Dark Souls games that inspired much of
Neos level design having a fastidious
exploratory mindset helps reveal a
locations many shortcuts the discoveries
of which are always satisfying
although the specter of potential
failure hangs heavy over any play
session dying in neo is never genuinely
disheartening this is thanks in part to
the various avenues of character growth
and the many approaches you can utilize
the technological section or boss fight
it shouldn't be surprising that the
foresight and patience needed to survive
a battle of Dark Souls would translate
well to the fundamentals of samurai
combat here
Neos most invigorating and intimidating
moments occur when you feel you're at
equal footing with your opponent and
it's during these encounters that one
careless move can result in your demise
or the right string of thoughtful
actions can make you feel invincible
[Music]
we do me